Hạng hả? Trần Nam nhau.
Trần Nam nhau.
Đâu!
Tăng lọc mơ xe.
Để bây giờ nãy giờ.
Đâu về là biết không hả?
Bây giờ, chỉ tháng 1 năm hành hủ chấp.
Còn hoàn sát cảm lâm.
Hẹn hoà, cho biết đơn vị vừa bất sử dụt từ trên á chủng chả có thể không có mị.
Chứ đó, qua con tắc nắm tình hình bọng,
đợi chức năng phát hiện bùng vừa đần ông hành hề trẻ xe không có mị.
Lên tục thây đổi nước tầm.
Trời, hôm nay trong sát cảm lâm,
nên tổn hành sắp mình và đã sát bị đỏ là vính trong bảo đang trong hành trình lần chốn cứ định trinh á.
Đến trường qua, tổ con tác sò thử ta khuôn thái hồng,
trình công a sát cám lâm trực tiếp chi vui cùng năm cắn bộ.
Chưa xí truy trạng, bắt sức đổ tự trước quán thật phía gà là C,
trên cước lộ một á, thuộc việc phần sát thăm lâm.
Này sóc khi bị bắt, lối tượng này đã thương nhận mình là vính trong bảo.
Xin năm, hồi, chú xá hòa sân, phần sân, tình đi thuật cứ.
Đó là đổ tự đả bị cơ quan cạnh sát đổ chá công a tình đi thuật phía tổ bị cán từng.
Nó, hành hình khu xam hai mít tư, về tự ra, về tự ra.
Xó bị cán cô tình là xó dò, để phương.
Này hai mì bày tháng hai năm hai nè, hình khu xam hai mì lâm,
cơ quan cạnh sát đổ chá công a cầu dễ.
Cảm sát có định trình á, trên tổng quốc thật, tự ra.
Hãy các bạn sát cám lâm đã chừng ra đổ tự trước quán cạnh sát đổ chá công a tình hả?
Tự tự ra và xưa tự ra.